bread's related retribution it's short
for yeah yes this is Riya cane which
which was a really bad thing for me
excuse me and my grade because I you
know studying English was changed but my
journey is like that so ever so as bad
so therefore I understand related rates
we really need first to make sure we
understand what I write to change which
we did last year okay so let me try and
remind you how it was the big idea
behind rates of change it was that we've
learnt all of this differentiation and
integration of business but for a long
time was very abstract
it was just lettuce variables we didn't
know what any of them met and in fact
what's the time none of them really
meant anything they were just letters
that followed values that follows
certain rules and they didn't really
refer to anything in life
so the idea behind rates of change is
that these two things these values of
these variables Y and X are actual
things things you can really measure
like say a population and a time right
and so a rate of change is has a
population change as time changes okay
and we looked at all kinds of different
examples of things that can change so
that was rates of change so what related
rates the idea is that you can have
multiple kinds of rates like this okay
which you can think of separately but
you can also think of as related to each
other in this way example let's think of
say a person and at least you know at
your age from age you know 0 up to I
think firm this is how everyone stands
isn't it up to whatever 18 or 21 or
maybe for you sadly like 16 our people
grow right so your height is a variable
to change
so you can consider the rate of change
of your height that's the change in
height over the change of time so see
how your height is changing and I guess
if I had to guess to be so like a monkey
right sort of starts offering the state
and then it gets but by the same token
it's not just your height the changes
right
it's also your weight the changes yes
right so everything gets above anyway so
weight is a whole different variable
gear right I don't want to go across
words because actually if that's not
weird right but wait you know I can
consider that over time as well right a
here are two rates and clearly they are
related clearly there's some kind of a
connection here okay now it's not just
by experience you know something gets
taller yeah her if it's getting heavier
right or vice versa but you can see
mathematically the relationship is well
it's actually written there isn't it
what's the thing that connects these two
it's time because there's a common
variable between the two of them okay we
can actually if we wanted the
relationship between height and weight
more directly without this intermediary
variable in between you'd say well let's
see how does height change as weight
changes come these two relate to each
other you'd say I can work that out by
taking this rate of change and multiply
it by this one okay now admittedly this
is not that it's a receiver
all of that but if you know what the
weight changes is you can work out what
its reciprocal is okay so the key idea
for related rates of change is not just
that these things actually stand further
values right but this to you let this
this has a name this is called the chain
rule right so the idea of related rates
is a chain rule isn't just some fancy
mathematical operation that helps you
differentiate integrate stuff right
that's nice okay
chain rule means that there are
different rates and they're related to
each other and you can come up with
their relationship if you put them
together in the right way okay